I want to go back to hearing more about
your distribution but first I want to
yeah talk about you actually drove from
LA to the Burning Man what is it
corporate office or whatever it is in
San Francisco and you met them face to
face yep yeah there's the Burning Man
headquarters is in San Francisco they
have a nice new office now in 2008 they
were on a different office but yeah you
know you submit on the internet you
submit your project you you upload your
project and then and then I actually got
to meet meet with them in person and we
talked you know we had a half hour 45
minute talk about the project about the
people involved about our intentions
about you know how we were going to
finish the project yeah have they ever
said no to people before yeah yeah yeah
all the time I think in 2008 there was
over a hundred proposals em and we were
one of a dozen that got approved so
every year there's there's a lot of
proposals and I think they're pretty
selective with what they approved
because they want to make sure that you
know they're valid documentary projects
was I'm sorry this was the first time
you'd ever been to burning man is that
right yep yep 2008 I think 22 of the 25
had never been we had a couple mentors
that had been a couple people that had
been many many many times and those
people were incredibly helpful with okay
how do we do this what do we bring
what's the right way of doing this how
is it going to work what's the city like
and of course I had done a ton of
research watching other documentaries
and so you kind of get the gist you know
it's going to be hot hot hot you know
it's going to be dusty you know what to
expect a little bit but I think it
always hits you with wow this is this is
a 50,000 person party hope these are a
lot of people and the range the range of
experiences out there is just amazing so
what do you think it was about your
project do you think it was just meeting
them face-to-face and them seeing your
sincerity
and the organization that you done
beforehand what do you think it was that
really said oh they said all right we'll
let you do this because they don't say
to everyone yeah it's different about
yours well what was different was that
our project proposal had multiple
directors which had never been done
before I actually don't know of any
project that has multiple directors in
the way that we have in our phone I've I
think part of it also was our fifty
percent rule our fifty-fifty rule which
was basically that you know fifty
percent of the time we're going to spend
not working on the project which is it's
you know it's different you know you're
going to be out there participating and
immersing yourself out there
you